- Il y a 10 ans, on obligeait
les compagnies de tabac
à tapisser les paquets
de cigarettes de photos
icicicites et de messages sur
les effets nocifs du tabac.
Cela a-t-il convaincu
les fumeurs d'écraser?
JEAN FLEURY, fumeur
- L'effet sur le paquet
de cigarettes, c'est dissuasif,
quand même, là.
On n'aime pas regarder
le paquet de cigarettes.
DENIS LACOMBE, fumeur
- Je crois qu'ils ont raison
de faire ça.
- Preuve que la partie n'est pas
gagnée : malgré tout, ces deux
fumeurs n'ont toujours pas
arrêté.
- J'avais arrêté ça
complètement. J'ai recommencé
il y a peut-être nsnsnsns.
- On touche, on retourne,
on arrête.
- Là, vous êtes
dans quelle période?
- Je fume un peu.
CAROLYN BENNETT, ministre féd.,
Santé mentale et Dépendances
- Le tabagisme continue
d'être une cause majeure
de maladies évitables.
- 48 000 Canadiens meurent
encore de maladies liées
au tabac, chaque année.
Ottawa fait le constat
qu'il faut aller encore plus
loin dans la lutte au tabagisme.
- Notre gouvernement propose
une mise à jour des règlements
pour l'étiquetage.
- Dorénavant, sur chaque
cigarette, un message
sera imprimé. Impossible
d'y échapper. Quelques mots
comme ceux-ci : "Du poison
dans chaque bouffée".
L'objectif est de réduire
de plus de la moitié le nombre
de fumeurs au Canada.
Ils représentent actuellement
13 % de la population.
Le gouvernement espère qu'il en
restera à peine 5 %, en 2035.- .
L'information n'est pas
toujours à jour.
- La Coalition québécoise
pour le contrôle du tabac
croit qu'il est grand temps
de mettre au goût du jour
la stratégie antitabac.
FLORY DOUCAS, codir., Coalition
québécoiselelelelele du tabac
- On en est rendus là.
Puis surtout, quand on tient
compte que plusieurs jeunes
vont s'échanger des cigarettes,
vont emprunter une cigarette,
i i i i i ils ne font pas
toujours l'achat d'un paquet.
- Mais elle ne se fait pas
d'illusion : elle s'attend
à une riposte des compagnies t .
- Elles ont la capacité
et l'argent pour changer
régulièrement leurs produits.
- Santé Canada va d'ailleurs
demander l'avis des compagnies
de tabac, en plus de tenir
des consultations publiques
qui s'étendront sur plus de
deux mois. Les p
cigarettes arborant un message
de santé publique seront en
vente au plus tôt à l'automne
2023.
Ici Valérie Gamache,
Radio-Canada, Ottaw